it's being called an historic day in the
fight against the coronavirus
covit 19 vaccinations have begun in
countries across the european union
the vaccine is seen as the first
significant step forward in a crisis
that has elevated health workers
and scientists to the rank of heroes now
it's the turn of a new type of hero to
roll up their sleeves with europe's most
elderly lining up for the vaccine
celebration as spain vaccinates its
first person against the coronavirus
it's a moment of hope in one of the
country's hardest hit by the pandemic
in italy medical staff were the first to
get the jab
their country too ravaged by the first
wave of a virus
having been on the front line since the
beginning of the pandemic
i have felt with my hands and seen with
my eyes how difficult it is to fight
this virus it has been painful to
witness the defeats this virus has
caused
but today is an important and decisive
day
in the czech republic prime minister
anja babish led the way
and he was followed by a world war ii
veteran
who took it all in her stride
it pricked a little that was all
while in sweden the first was a 91 year
old retirement home resident
supply of a vaccine is limited but
demand is
huge with most eu countries receiving an
initial batch of no more than 10
000 doses each member state is
prioritizing who gets the jab
further supplies are expected in the new
year but officials warn there's a long
way to go before everyone can be
vaccinated
our brussels bureau chief alexander von
neumann is standing by for us in
brussels alexandra
a historic day in the fight against this
pandemic what's the
eu's role in this vaccine rollout
eu commission president ozola fonda lyon
described it as a touching
moment of europe's unity and this was
exactly what the european union was
aiming for
in this phase of the fight against the
corona virus
the member states could have moved
forward individually
but instead they decided that it is the
european commission
talking to pharmaceutical companies
procuring
vaccines and coordinating the rollout of
vaccines now across the continent across
the block
and it was important to make sure that
every member state is getting vaccines
at the same time and that
even poorer member state are not being
left behind
left alone with that countries like the
us and the uk have already begun
vaccinating people why did it take the
eu
longer to get there it took longer
indeed and the reason for that was that
vaccines in the u.s
and in the uk were approved under the
emergency use authorization the european
union decided to
approve them under con conventional
market authorization
it was because of questions of liability
if there are
any serious side effects and it was also
meant as a signal to show that the
vaccine is safe
and to convince those who are still
skeptical
that it's safe and and rights to get
vaccinated
now something that won't help skeptics i
suppose the head of the
european european police body europol
has warned against the danger of
potential fake coronavirus vaccines
what more can you tell us about that
well
that's true europol has been warning of
fake vaccines for a while now
saying that there is a danger that
organized crime could try to sell
counterfeit
vaccines or try to hijack shipments of
genuine vaccines
and that is of course because we don't
have enough doses uh
and uh um there are people maybe
desperate to
get vaccinated who would buy a vaccine
on dark net
dark web so that is why europol is
warning member states to
stay uh vigilant uh because there is a
real danger that criminal minds could
try to
to sell fake vaccines all right
alexander von neumann speaking to us
from brussels thank you for that update
and here in germany where infections and
numbers of coveted deaths have reached
record highs in recent weeks
one care home decided it didn't want to
waste any time after taking delivery of
the vaccine
a 101 year old woman in the state of
saxenan halt got the first
was the first to get the shot a day
earlier than scheduled
those in the highest priority group
include people over 80
as well as residents and staff of care
homes
and kate martyr is standing by for us at
the largest retirement home
in cologne germany of course uh kate
what's happening right now where you are
um so just behind me is the first woman
who got vaccinated here today she's a
1992 year old uh
lady named frau fergal so mrs fogel
um and yet she was vaccinated today the
first of 110 residents here
at cologne's largest care home where
there's 1
100 residents so she was the first of
many
and everyone here who will get
vaccinated everyone here who wants to
get vaccinated
will be able to do so in the coming days
but just today there will be
110 uh residents here vaccinated
and a number of staff as well and can
you tell us a little bit more about how
people are reacting to this news and
having
you know i guess the media there and
this event unrolling
uh in the in their own care home
yeah everyone was really really excited
today um and
frau fogle mrs foger herself is also
really happy um as soon as she had the
vaccination she pulled down her
face mask like my one here and she did a
large smile
and everyone was very very happy about
that and i spoke as well to the woman
um the head of the care home here as
well and she said
um that she was very excited that her
care home had been the first one
chosen to for these vaccinations to
happen and she said that a lot of hard
work had gone
into um preparing the vaccine and making
sure all the preparations were right and
that took place through christmas but
she called it an early christmas present
yeah and we can well imagine why thanks
for that kate martyr reporting for us
from cologne
and to shed a little more light on this
historic day we're joined now by andrew
ullman from wurzburg
he's a member of the bundestag for the
business friendly ftp party and a member
of the german health alliance advisory
board mr ullman welcome to the program
the european commission president says
this is a touching moment
of unity for europe is it
i would say so i think it's a very
touchy moment since for the first time
in human history
we are combating a pandemic an acute
pandemic
with a newly evaluated and approved
vaccine
and i think that is a major step in
humankind
germany where we're both living and
talking in lockdown at one kind or
another didn't deal with the second wave
of the pandemic as well as the first
why is that
well i think there was a certain kind of
ignorance on one side and
some kind of a hopefulness that this
nightmare would pass by
without any consequences i think that
was a
big blind spot by the the german
government
and we see it right now with a very high
infection rates and especially the
vulnerable groups
are especially hit hard they are in the
icu being
on the respirator or even dying because
they were not well enough
protected i think there has to be a lot
of work up to be done afterwards why
that happened
because it was always uh clear that
we're going to have a second wave
we wanted to prevent a second lockdown
and it was very important for us
to prevent any kind of infection
especially nursery homes
for the elderly and i think there was a
lot of things that were missed
all right and this you're a member of
parliament tell me is there not a
form of structural political weakness in
germany vis-a-vis pandemics chancellor
merkel had a very hard time getting
regional
leaders to agree to to a lockdown has
that shown up weaknesses in the federal
system do you think that need fixing
perhaps
i think once this pandemic is over we
have to discuss the federal system in
germany in regards
to pandemic preparedness it is very
clear that we were not prepared
for the pandemic in march of this year
and we were not prepared
for the second wave at all very well
because
health care and health systems are in
the
uh responsibility of the different
states in germany
and of course there were certain kinds
of minister presidents
that were very much interested to see
how strong they are
but they actually demonstrated more
weakness because the unity
of our country or even within europe
wasn't uh guaranteed
and it caused a lot of let's say a mess
up
in prevention measures that were done in
our country
thank you for that insight andrew illman
member of the bundestag and the german
health alliance
thank you for having me
and here in germany the immunization
campaign is already
underway with vaccine doses still in
limited supply the government has
prioritized who will go first
those in the highest priority group
include people over 80
as well as residents and staff of care
homes frontline medical personnel in
intensive care units and emergency
services
and others in contact with high-risk
patients also get
priority after that the vaccination will
be given to people over 70
doctors and medical staff in regular
contact with patients
as well as people with mental
disabilities everyone else
will have to wait it's not yet clear how
the rest of the population will be
prioritized
the question remains just how long it
will take for enough people to be
vaccinated for life to return
to some kind of normal
now let's head to italy where there's a
massive vaccine roll out
um joined by dw correspondent sema gupta
in rome
seema the vaccine program now underway
there how's it going
yes it's kicked off this morning with
the first five people
are being vaccinated here in rome a
nurse a virologist
and other healthcare workers were the
first to be
vaccinated in an infectious disease
hospital here in rome
now it's rather symbolic because of
course this hospital was also where
the very first cases were treated back
in january
uh four covet 19. um the prime minister
giuseppe conte calling the fact that
this date the 27th of december
will go down in history italy of course
having suffered greatly at the hands of
kovic 19
more than 71 000 people have died
due to this virus in this second wave
the number of dead
is higher already than that first wave
uh more than two million people
have been infected with covet 19 here
now the health minister said that this
is the first sign of light that they are
seeing
but you cannot let your guard down the
vaccine doesn't mean
that you can stop the mars or stop the
social distinct
or distancing or washing hands he said
all of that has to continue
9750 doses of that pfizer vaccine
are delivered across the country the
largest number of doses going to that
hardest hit region of lombardy up north
well italy is of course one of the
hardest hit countries in europe you
mentioned some of those alarming numbers
is there enough vaccine to bring about a
change in the spreading of the virus in
italy
well what the authorities are saying is
that they've ordered a total of 202
million
doses now that includes pfizer as well
as all the other different companies
uh they expect the the vaccines from
moderna to come
in early january as well they've got 21
centers uh where they're going to hit
out for the initial doses
and eventually uh you're going to see a
massive program a campaign if you like
to inform people about why it's
important to do this vaccine that's free
and non-mandatory but is very much
encouraged
and some 1 500 vaccination pavilions
are going to be set up in piazzas or
squares around the country to administer
these doses
to the general population the first
though will go up to those healthcare
workers
as well as the those in nursing homes
and those over 80
eventually uh going down to those over
65
as well as teachers policemen those
in the front line who are most exposed
and eventually to the general population
the scientists believe
that by september you will have an
element
of normalcy if you like in the country
but of course
it's still early days and still early
hours really in this program
all right sima gupta speaking to us from
italy who started their vaccination
program today thanks very much
and for more insight on the rollout
across europe i'm joined from seville by
dw correspondent yen philip schultz
uh yan spain as we heard and as you know
full well was one of the worst hit
countries in europe
is there enough vaccine there to change
things fast enough
well from today on spain will receive
350
000 doses every week they will be
brought to a hub in the center of the
country
and then they will be distributed to the
different
regions it's probably enough for the
most vulnerable group
for the care home residents and the
staff of
care homes they have been the hardest
hit ten thousands of care home residents
have died here in spain so the
government is hopeful
that there is enough vaccine for them
so that the majority of them will be
covered in the next
12 weeks and how are people in spain
reacting to the vaccination campaign
imagine there's some relief but are
people
keen to get inoculated
well according to the latest surveys
most spaniards are quite
optimistic a lot of them think it's the
famous
light at the end of the tunnel and if
you speak to
people on the streets they also say they
think it's a good idea
that it's a concerted effort in the
european union
accordingly there was a slight
irritation yesterday when you spread
that a few places and some countries
including germany started already with
the vaccination
um of course the the the agreed
official date is is today so there was
slight irritation
but now everybody is looking forward to
the
program and just hopeful that this will
be really the last phase of the pandemic
now
all right dw zian philipp schultz in
seville thank you for that
and another hard-hit country in europe
has of course been france and we're
joined now from the french capital
by dw correspondent sonia falmouth sonia
thanks for being here
how is the vaccination program being
rolled out in france
well so france has indeed begun with its
vaccinations today though i have to say
on a very small scale only about a dozen
people in a few nursing homes
uh near paris and and near burgundy uh
were the first to get vaccinated today
that included a 78-year
woman in in in an um old age home in
sevilla near near paris and this is very
much in line with what the french
government has been saying
namely that it will you know carry out
these vaccinations in a slow
and and phased out manner starting with
the most vulnerable group that is
high-risk elderly patients and the
people who care for them
in the countries uh 14 000 nursing homes
and we have to remember these nursing
homes
also accounted for a large number of the
more than 60 000 deaths that we've seen
in france so far
uh linked to the coronavirus um france
as we know when you know stands out not
just for the high level
of coronavirus cases but also the high
level of coronavirus and vaccine
skepticism
compared to other european countries
what's being done to counter that to
have this rollout succeed
that is true i mean you know many people
here remain deeply skeptical of the
vaccine and according to the
government's own
most recent health survey just about 40
of the french population say that they
will get the vaccine so this is deeply
worrying
the government has really responded by
saying that they will not make the
vaccine compulsory this week we saw
french health minister oliveiran say
saying that france would not be rushing
into into this campaign he's he's made
it clear that
anyone who opts for this vaccine will
will you know receive a medical
consultation they will get information
about the
about the vaccine they will have to give
their consent and he says all this is an
attempt to boost
you know confidence in the vaccine
health officials here have also been
saying that they will publish a report
every week with any possible side
effects
which have not been reported early in
clinical trials so i think the french
government is really making a big effort
to
tell people we're taking your concerns
seriously we're moving very slowly with
this but we do hope to take um
everyone on board okay dws sonia
falnikar in paris thanks for that
insight
hungary also started vaccinating ahead
of the eu schedule starting with its
hospital staff
also using the beyond tech pfizer
vaccine it got its first
shipments of nearly 10 000 doses the
government is prioritizing frontline
healthcare staff
the first worker to be given the shot
was a senior physician at budapest
central hospital a mass vaccination
program is then planned for early 2021.
and for more on this let's turn to
journalist stephan boss in
budapest stefan hungary is uh
starting as vaccinations ahead of many
other eu countries as germany has we've
just heard
what's what's behind that reasoning
i think behind that reasoning is that
the hungarian prime minister viktor
orban who has been criticized by the
opposition
over his perceived lacking in the
coronavirus pandemic measures
that he wants to show that he is still
in control and i think it's also
a message towards europe he had a
very tense relationship with the
european union and he wants to show them
that
hungary can stand its own and we can
care for our people
now at the same time of course time is
running out
the critics say because the death toll
is actually
rising here there are almost 9 000
people reportedly
died with or because of corona virus on
a
population of nearly 10 million people
but
that is i think also behind the
reasoning for the prime minister
to do this tonight and today it's also
not the first time that hungary has been
in the news about its vaccination plans
when it came out that hungary was
actually going to go a different way
from the eu
not wait for that beyond tech pfizer
maybe go with the chinese or the russian
vaccines as well what more do you know
about that
well what i know is that in fact already
some
russian doses of that sputnik vaccine
arrived here in hungary they have been
testing it
and if it's up to the hungarians they
will roll out that very soon
the same they are saying about the
chinese vaccine as well
and uh as hunger is concerned there's
nothing wrong with doing that now of
course
there are people disagreeing including
the european union they say
these vaccines should be tested much
better
but of course there is a loophole in
legislation
also within europe and that's i think
that loophole
will be used by the prime minister to
bring more vaccines
perhaps even here behind me in this
hospital as was done today with the
pfizer vaccine what's been the public
reaction there to
these various kinds of vaccines do
people seem like they're going to want
to step up to get it when they can
well it's depending on who's whom you
talk i've been speaking with several
hungarians and they say
i don't want to be vaccinated they are
very concerned about it to be honest but
of course if you speak with elderly
people they might appreciate it
i think also what we could hear today is
that the frontline workers they
are very happy that the vaccines arrived
they say many of us
were infected in fact with golfit
and that's also in part i have to say
because there is a rundown
health system in hungary so it depends
on who you thought but i think
many people are happy here tonight
stefan boss in budapest
thanks very much
you